bonjour robert ménard merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france alors grosse journée hier pour
holly et veyran il a été auditionné à
l'assemblée et au sénat et le ministre
n'a pas vraiment convaincu les les
sénateurs notamment sur le calendrier
vaccinal certains doutent même de la
possibilité de rattraper ce retard à
l'allumage quel est votre sentiment
écoutez moi je le trouve un peu alors
j'allais dire gonflé c'est un peu
vulgaire mais je le trouve un peu
audacieux notre ministre de la santé
je vous rappelle quelques nombre de
bêtises qui nous a raconté le nombre de
promesses qu'il a faites et qu'il n'a
pas respectée il devrait un peu plus
prudent un peu plus modeste reconnaître
par exemple que non c'est pas une
stratégie c'est une erreur en ce moment
c'est un manque de logistique mais
rappelez vous au printemps c'est le même
ministère qui nous expliquait que les
masques ça ne servait à rien que les
masses étaient inutiles c'est est
nuisible m'avait dit ici son
représentant le préfet de l'hérault pour
nous dire trois semaines après qu'il
faut qu'on entend qu'il fallait qu'on en
parle qu'on emporte tous et maintenant
on emporte tous même chose avec les
tests vont appeler les tests moi je me
souviens j'avais demandé au préfet de
pouvoir tester vous savez tout le
personnel tout le personnel et des
écoles c'était à la reprise de l'école
au mois de mai pour rassurer les parents
pour rassurer les enseignants on m'a
répondu mais tout ça ça ça et on va
quand même pas testé tout le monde
maintenant vous explique qu'il faut
tester tout le monde et maintenant ils
rebeloter ont recommencé le même souli
est le même se verront le même ministre
explique annoncé penser c'est volontaire
on a réfléchi si on a fait alors je
cherche fléchi au audouze là si on n'a
fait que 190 milles vaccination c'est
quasiment volontaire mais de qui se
moque taux de qui se moque t'on c'est
qu'une fois de plus les problèmes de
logistique d'intendance comme aurait dit
charles de gaulle on l'est on les a pas
pris en compte et on les a pas assumer
et on les a pas préparé
enfin vous voyez en israël quoi c'est un
quart de la population où un tiers de la
population un quart de la population qui
est vacciné nous 190 milles
soit sur 6 sur 65 millions d'habitants
et non honnêtement c'est pas sûr il
faudrait quand même moi je donne pas de
leçons mais je demande au gouvernement
et à monsieur véran de faire preuve de
modestie quand on s'est trompé quand on
n'a pas bien préparé les choses on le
dit et on dit on va changer les choses
et peut-être qu'on s'appuie un peu plus
sur les mers d'ailleurs soit dit en
passant et on va en parler justement une
des méandres on continue justement sur
les sénateurs leur sentiment hier après
l'audition et d'olivier ferrand qui
parle de 77 millions de doses d'ici fin
juin 21 millions en mars elle les
sénateurs doute de ces chiffres avancés
par le ministre ma question c'est vous
parliez des masques comment ça se passe
au niveau local aujourd'hui est ce que
vous êtes en mesure de vacciner toutes
les personnes de plus de 75 ans puisque
le feu a été le feu vert a été donné
pour elle aujourd'hui être leno
seulement aujourd'hui on n'a pas les
moyens de le faire mais vous savez on a
un centre que communal de vaccination
qu'on a mis évidemment à la disposition
des autorités
et c'est notre travail de le faire pour
vous savez le personnel de plus de 50
ans ou qui a un certain nombre de
problèmes physiques
le personnel soignant écoutez évidemment
n'a pas pu vacciner tous les gens qui
nous l'ont demandé
là je vous parle que du personnel sur
les ongles et bientôt et je ne vous
parle pas des personnes de toutes les
personnes de plus de 75 ans attendez on
avait reçu pour vous dire samedi
puisqu'on a commencé samedi
on avait reçu 25 25
le lien entendu 25 et en tout et pour
tout vingt-cinq vaccination on avait
enfin l'or dans la journée plus de 200
demandes de gens dans le personnel 25 12
25 12 on en a reçu plus maintenant mais
on n'est pas à la hauteur des demandes
si vous ajoutez tout le personnel qui a
besoin aujourd'hui tout le personnel
soignant au sens là les médecins les
infirmières et les pharmaciens enfin
tous les gens qui accueillera à voir de
près ou de loin avec la santé non de n'a
pas les moyens donc je ne crois pas un
instant qu'on ait la possibilité
aujourd'hui de vacciner tous les gens
qui nous le demandent alors si non il
faut faire des miracles mais pour
l'instant des miracles je n'ai pas vu l
on a entendu et les vers ont parlé des
plateformes privées justement pour la
prise de
rendez vous pour faire vacciner les
personnes quelque peu critiqué justement
ce caractère privé compensées vous est
ce que ça peut être une solution
est ce qu'il y à beaucoup d'inscrits sur
la ville de béziers c'est trop compliqué
madame aujourd'hui c'est trop compliqué
aujourd'hui entre l'entretien que vous
avec le médecin
levac si la vaccia la vaccination
elle-même et le quart d'heure qu'on vous
demande de nous on vous demande de
rester là pour voir s'il n'y a pas de
problème quoi ça a duré 40 minutes et
attendez c'est pas possible il faut
simplifier les choses multiplient mais
les lieux et s'appuyer pas que sur les
toits public attend dé moi j'ai entendu
des 'pharmas' et ça me semble bon sens
dire qu'ils sont capables de vacciner
plus d'un million de personnes en une
semaine c'est qu'il s'agit de la grippe
mais faisons confiance à un certain
nombre de gens j'espère qu'on va tirer
les leçons de ça et j'espère que demain
puisque oui on est demain cessé jeudi le
monsieur castex notre premier liste va
faire en sorte que les choses soient
plus simples et aille plus vite
si la vaccination est la solution et
c'est ce qu'on nous respecte de répète
depuis des semaines et des mois
il faut aller vite et mettre le plus
vite possible le plus grand nombre
possible de gens à l'abri du cours d'un
virus
olivier viron été vivement interpellé
par françois ruffin hier à l'assemblée
il lui a demandé pourquoi le vaccin et
sanofi ne faisait pas partie des vaccins
qui était sur le marché aujourd'hui
écoutés pourquoi sanofi n'a pas son
vaccin mais je comprends que vous ne
répondiez pas parce que l'échec de
sanofi c'est l'échec de la macro ni café
sanofi depuis dix ans ses dirigeants ont
licencié la moitié de leurs chercheurs
ce groupe comptait onze laboratoires en
france
il en reste aujourd'hui 3 sanofi s'est
désengagé de tous les traitements non
rentables mais tous les profits vont aux
actionnaires l'an dernier encore en
plein confinement la firme battait un
nouveau record 4 milliards d'euros de
dividendes et en même temps comme tous
les ans sanofi annoncé la suppression de
1700 emplois
est ce qu'il ya une raison d'interpeller
olivier ferrand françois ruffin
absolument ce qui est dit je souscris il
absolument réseau à un détail près qui
est un détail mais qui n'est pas rien
c'est que c'est pas que la macro ni
pardon j'ai le souvenir avant de
monsieur hollande je pense qu'ils
étaient pas vraiment à droite il était
plutôt à gauche et je ne crois pas que
monsieur hollande ait changé grand-chose
qui sont des entreprises françaises
jeudi il n'a pas fait revenir un certain
nombre de gens là je veux dire il ya
tout un courant et ça que ça concerne
pas monsieur rufin donc je mets pas en
cause ce monsieur le fait mais il faut
dire que c'est pas que monsieur macro
c'est d'ailleurs je m'accroche je vous
rappelle qu'il a été le ministre
monsieur de monsieur hollande il ya tout
il ya tout un monde tout un monde
aujourd'hui en gros la gauche libérale
et la droite libérale qui a oublié qu'il
fallait construire des frontières et il
fallait à l'intérieur de ce conte guerre
chez nous il fallait développer au moins
maintenir une activité industrielle une
activité de production
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des
médicaments fin ces jours des portes
jean fau dépendent sous verre sont
fabriqués ailleurs quand aussi on l'a vu
mais pas que l'école et que les mini
cars ont appelé masque rappelez-vous les
masques quand même pas une haute
technologie on a l'impression on a
constaté qu'on peut être qu'on n'y en
avait pas en france donc oui il ya un
travail de re localisation et c'est le
chantier qui s'ouvre c'est le chantier
qui s'ouvre pour propose pour le nouveau
gouvernement parce que je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse sérieusement compter sur le
schéma crocs pour mener cette politique
qui à l'opposé de tout ce qu'il a
toujours prônés tout le long tout au
long de sa vie et de son engagement
politique
robert ménard il ya un nouveau conseil
de défense ce matin des annonces
devraient être faites demain un couvre
feu généralisé à 18 heures pourraient
être annoncées est ce que vous y êtes
favorable c'est notamment pour faire
face à ce fameux vario anglais du virus
écoutez si c'est nécessaire il faut le
faire je pense que c'est évidemment
mieux ça que un recond films en général
qui voudrait dire quoi qui voudrait dire
qu'on referme tous les commerces et tous
et ce serait d'un point de vue
économique une catastrophe pour notre
pays
mais oui il ya gaz et à tours 2
qui se dégradent mémoire bon là je suis
à béziers j'ai mis cette nuit les
chiffres de l'hérault et de et demain
vire et la situation sanitaire se
dégrade et s'il est nécessaire de faire
de maître à un conflit entre deux feux
de ramener à 18 heures le couvre-feu oui
il faut le faire
moi je suis pas à quelqu'un qui dit un
non tout ça n'est pas grave bien sûr que
tout ça est gras bien sûr que tout ça
est compliqué bien sûr tout ça nous
réserve des surprises bien sûr que dans
ces conditions là je donne pas je le
répète je ne fais pas des leçons de
morale tous les jours gouvernement mais
il ya un certain nombre de choses qu'il
n'a pas bien est ce que vous faites
partie de ceux qui préféreraient décidé
au niveau local comme le demandent
certains maires je pense qu'il faut
demander leur appui au maire qui connaît
mieux béziers que moi honnêtement
sérieusement le préfet le préfet de
l'hérault
il pense que le prélat près les roues ça
se réduit à ça ça métropole c'est à dire
à montpellier comme comme les élites
françaises pense que là il n'y a de bons
becs qu'à paris comme les élites des
régions ne pense que la seule chose
pense que la seule chose qui compte
c'est les rétros pôle régional le nom il
faut s'appuyer sur les mers c'est les
maires qui connaissent le mieux c'est
les mères qui prennent le mieux le tour
de leur population et donc je souhaite
sans arrêt je le répète qu'on me demande
mon avis pas parce que c'est moi
personnellement mais parce que les mères
sont bien placés pour donner cet avis là
oui faut voir si c'est là mais la
situation n'est pas la même à brest à
béziers à strasbourg alors il faut
adapter les mesures aux différentes
offres aux différentes situations
on l'a fait monsieur maquereau et le
gouvernement l'ont fait avec la le
couvre-feu ramener à 18 heures il faut
continuer à le faire est de demander
leur avis aux élus locaux
oui merci robert ménard d'avoir répondu
ce matin en direct à nos questions dans
la matinale d'ayrté france